[Musique]
1669 si Étienne réot qui crée
Saint-Denis en 1669 estime que ce
quartier est destiné à devenir le centre
du commerce et du gouvernement il faut
attendre 1738 pour que MAE de la
bourdonné en fasse officiellement le
chef-lieu de lî le coin sauvage à
proximité d'une baie naturelle se
transforme alors en ville
en
1774 le chevalier Banks arpenteur du roi
dessine les plans de la capitale comme
un damier de rue étroite à angle droit
le bas de la ville est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui encore identique érigé en
commune en 1790 du fait de la Révolution
française la Ville poursuit tout au long
du 19e siècle son embellissement du
jardin de l'État au Barachois en passant
par la rue de Paris Saint-Denis devient
rapidement le centre administratif
économique et culturel de lîle et joue
un rôle crucial dans l'histoire
politique de la
Réunion près de 160000 dionisiens
participent aujourd'hui quotidiennement
au rayonnement de ces quartiers
touristiques du cœur de ville à ses
banlieux industriels et
commercial cette vieille dame de plus de
350 ans est à présent une ville
connectée au monde
entier
1669 création de la ville de
[Musique]
Saint-Denis